après des années de divisions les
leaders de l'otan retrouvent leur unité
face à un ennemi commun et aux horreurs
de la guerre en ukraine
selon louis qui dit des adultes et des
enfants ont encore été tués a déclaré le
président ukrainien dans un message
vidéo destiné aux leaders de l'otan
alliance
l'alliance peut encore empêcher la mort
d'ukrainiens souligne volodymyr elin ce
qui en nous donnant toutes les armes
dont nous avons besoin un patient il a
de nouveau réclamé des chars d'assaut et
des avions de chasse une protection du
ciel ukrainien mais la réponse de l'otan
n'est pas à la hauteur de ses attentes
oui responsabiltés chuck the conflict
death note et squelettes feu de l'otan
veut éviter de se placer en
confrontation directe avec la russie
pour l'instant l'alliance se contente
d'ajouter quatre groupements tactiques
en europe de l'est devant la menace
d'une attaque chimique biologique ou
nucléaires de la russie l'otan fournira
de l'équipement spécialisé à l'ukraine
pour se protéger le président américain
lors d'un avertissement à vladimir
poutine
nous répliquerons s'ils utilisent des
armes chimiques le secrétaire général de
l'otan lance lui aussi un message cette
fois à ses propres alliés parce que
l'été 230 offrit en deux mots au
crockmore la sécurité n'est pas gratuite
en faire plus coûtera plus cher le
budget militaire du canada est encore
loin de la cible de l'alliance justin
trudeau promet de l'augmenter sans être
plus précis nos investissements dans nos
forces armées vont continuer à augmenter
et on en aura que c'est à dire en temps
et lieu pour maintenir la pression sur
moscou ottawa ajoute 160 responsables
russes à sa liste de sanctions afin de
réduire la dépendance des européens
envers le pétrole russe le canada
augmentera ses exportations
d'hydrocarbures de 300 mille barils par
jour d'ici la fin de 2020 de premier
ministre refuse d'y voir une
contradiction avec ses engagements
climatiques nous sommes déterminés et à
continuer à protéger et à lutter contre
les changements climatiques
et d'assurer que la russie ne profite
aucunement de cette guerre il justin
trudeau petit le quartier général de
l'otan sans avoir annoncé de nouvelles
contributions militaires spécifiques et
en laissant ses alliés avec un vague
engagement d'augmenter ses dépenses en
défense c'est lors du dépôt du budget
fédéral au début du mois d'avril que les
canadiens pourront vraiment mesurer le
sérieux de son engagement ici louis
blouin radio-canada bruxelles